[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to the data
science Hangout
if you're joining us for the very first
time today this is an open space for the
whole data science Community to connect
and chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
learn about what's going on in the world
of data science at different companies
across different Industries and these
sessions are recorded and they are
shared to the posit YouTube which is the
first time I'm referring to something as
as posit which is exciting too so you
can always go back and re-watch or find
helpful resources there as well
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everyone
and we love when everybody can
participate and we can hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or area of work
so there's always three ways that you
can ask questions today
and also provide your perspective it
doesn't just have to be questions you
can jump in by raising your hand on Zoom
you could put questions into the zoom
chat
and feel free to just put a little star
there if you want me to read it out loud
instead
and then we also have our slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too if you prefer to ask there
um I did want to also mention
um the team at Lander analytics had
recently just shared with me the r in
government conference which is happening
in I think about a month now in December
the 1st of December and they gave me a
20 percent
promo discount for anybody in this group
who's interested in going to that
conference too so I'll share it here in
the chat I just wanted to to mention it
if it's of of interest to anybody
um but yes going back to going back to
the normal Spiel we do also have a
LinkedIn group for the hangout so if it
helps you connect with people or you
want to continue a discussion you can do
so there as well and our team will share
that in the chat in just a second
but for today I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host and our friend from
The Hangout here Alan schusman Alan is
data science and engineering team leader
at WL Gore and Associates
and Alan I know you've been here uh with
us quite a few weeks but I'd love to
have you introduce yourself and share a
little bit about your role and maybe
something you like to do outside of work
too
sure yeah um so I'm sure we'll get into
like lots of details about the role so I
won't like deep dive into that quite yet
um but yeah I work for WL Gordon
Associates Gore is the company the folks
probably know
um from Gore-Tex
um in Flagstaff we in Arizona Gore
researches and designs and manufactures
medical devices primarily endovascularly
implanted devices for a variety of
cardiovascular diseases
um and I work I have landed for the last
handful of years in this role as a a
daily team leader lots of trajectory of
change of that team and the role over
the last uh handful of years
um and we can we can dig into that um
I've been in Flagstaff I live in
Flagstaff I've been here for
um longer longer than I realized each
time I think about how long I've been
here I've been in Flagstaff about 17
years now and
um it's a it's a great town we're having
our first winter storm of the year right
now
um prior to coming to gore I did a PhD
in sociology and then thought about okay
what now what I want to do with my life
uh and so so here I am
um yeah I'll pause there um and I can I
can talk a bunch more about the the team
that I'm on about Gore MPD and how we
fit into things or happy to kind of head
in any direction that folks are are
interested in um in talking about and
eager for for feedback and uh and stuff
from from the team here
awesome thanks Alan and I know in your
free time maybe paddle boarding is one
of the things
um yeah you know our it's so dry here
our little Reservoir has been really
depressing uh this this summer so I
haven't I didn't get out much
um every time I walked the dog in the
woods a lot
um uh I like to take pictures
um I a whole bunch of my hobby time is
is our coding in the service of doing
things that are sometimes useful with
the destiny 2 API
um that's a lot of my my hobby time is
Video Game Plus data
um and uh yeah that's fun
cool well
I know you have a little bit of a
different title than some of the leaders
we've had on before and you manage both
data science and engineering teams and I
was just curious to learn a little bit
about that experience and kind of what
your team looks like too yeah sure so my
team
um the the work that my team primarily
does is data engineering
um we are part of and I guess this is
you know sort of primer on the on the
team in general in the past year and a
half we've switched from being a sales
and marketing oriented analytics team to
being a divisionally facing team and so
in that time we've taken on a ton of
um the the broad team of which we're
apart has grown tremendously and my team
has grown a bunch I think the way to
understand my team is like pragmatic
data engineering along a very broad
Continuum so there's some there is some
of what I think we would think of as
data science in in that work in so far
as we're asked to do some things around
um segmentation and do some some
modeling but a lot of those things are
for us
kind of applications and methodologies
that are waiting for the right business
cases to really put them to use and so
we are really heavily focused on getting
data to a broad team of analysts who
need to do all kinds of different things
with it
and we have both brought up and also
sort of inherited as teams have come to
us a really broad set of applications to
do that with of platforms and
Technologies and so we are both
um so when I say we're you know this is
pragmatic data engineering we are
solving problems as fast as we can we're
gaining credibility as we do that as we
do that the team gets to grow and we get
to think about where do we want to
strategically go how do we want to be
strategic about our platforms and things
while still being really really heavily
focused on getting data stuff done for
our really really diverse set of of uh
of customers and constituents
um and so the folks on my team are some
of them have formal data science
training in terms of of accreditations
and and degrees
there's a mix of folks who come from
different kinds of software engineering
background
um and let's see who else is on the team
um and folks who come from from more
business facing sort of sort of
backgrounds who came into analytics by
virtue of kind of being analysts and
developing in really technical
directions so it's a really broad team
and we're all focused on
different kinds of
um of applications and solutions of
making data available sometimes through
a bunch of really complex Mechanics for
our set of end users who again are are
going to do all kinds of different
things with it and so we're sort of at
the Crux of this operation of
um of data problem solving and it's
really exciting and as I said as we're
as we're growing we're getting some
opportunity that we haven't had in the
past to try to be more strategic
um about how do we want to grow what
kinds of tools do we want to use how
will we use them what kinds of processes
will we have those kinds of things
um so it's um it's you know we're kind
of racing to to
um to do good stuff for the business and
also for me I really want to sort of do
well by the folks on my team and give
them give them paths that let them grow
in ways that they're that they're
interested in growing and that's where
we we're looking to you know some sort
of aspirational data science kind of
kind of future States I guess
absolutely and when you say end users
across the company who who is that or
who are the different teams that you
work with so um we we have kind of a
couple of maybe concentric Rings um we
have our broad MPD analytics team is a
team now of about 50 or so my team is
about seven and the the rest of those 50
people are analysts and others who are
affiliated with we kind of have have
dotted functional lines to different
kinds of functions within the
organization so they're connected to
sales and marketing they're connected to
uh supply chain and Manufacturing
they're connected to uh quality and
Regulatory
and they're largely they're largely
analysts who are who have
responsibilities to their teams to
produce analyzes of different kinds
um
monitoring data
um strategic planning information those
kinds of things and so my team helps to
you know feed capabilities to them and
then also work as project partners with
them on the various things that that
they need to do
um and then so we are all part of one
big MPD analytics team but our sort of
customer basing orientations are all are
all really different and my team is the
one that sort of spans all of those
pillars of different functional and
business teams which means we get to see
and do a lot of different stuff yeah
great thank you I see Libby you asked a
question you want to jump in
yeah I was wondering if you had any
engineering or I.T background before you
came into this or if you just kind of
like grew into that at Gore because I
know sociology has quantitative elements
to it right so I'm sure you already had
some of that stuff what was your kind of
journey into the engineering side
um yeah I I guess there's a story there
you're absolutely right I mean the
social background was the thing that I
presented as a way to say hey I could do
I could be not an academic and not an
academic could look like a bunch of the
following things I could work with data
I could do stats um I could do some you
know programming of different kinds I
could do research so my entry into Gore
was kind of pitching myself to the
clinical research team and that's where
I started in Gore as a data a clinical
data manager so I was doing
um you know data uh data collection
design for clinical studies essentially
and then monitoring of data that came in
and those kinds of things and the you
know so the through line there was hey I
I could understand how research Works
albeit in a really different field and
can figure out how to work with data in
various ways okay I could be a data
manager my my jump from from there at
Gore was into an I.T role where so I
sort of translated those kinds of things
into saying hey I could fill a new
commitment here that has to do with
strategic planning of I.T stock for the
for the clinical team
um that role and that was a business
partner role and and that role gradually
expanded to doing it strategy things for
our our whole division which gave me
lots of exposure to different businesses
as well as the different kinds of
businesses and functions as well as the
different kinds of technical needs that
that they had so I got to see what you
know our scientists need to work with in
terms of technical tools and things like
that as well as exposure to sales and
marketing and so on
um so I mean you know that and then at
some point I said hey I've sort of been
ready to do something new and an
opportunity came along to
join this then very very small analytics
team that was trying to to figure things
out
um and and I and I jumped on it
um but so no like that's the really
really long answer to your question of
like like no I'm not I'm not trained as
a software engineer
um or as I don't know probably any of
the things I do day to day but there's a
sort of through line from from the stuff
I've done along the way that has has
helped me kind of figure it out as I go
I guess enough to
um enough to be okay at it and to be
successful at it sometimes if there's
any through line I think there's a lot
of enthusiasm for you know working with
these technical tools that I get
rewarded by finding success in and
gradually getting better enough at those
that I can can do more complex things I
guess
um and now as a leader I think that's a
whole new space of learning for me is
how to
um you know what the successful
leadership look like
um and so I'm working on figuring that
out
that's some of my favorite things at the
Hangouts is learning people's journey to
get to the role that they're in now and
then it's not always like you have
exactly the role that you or the degree
that you would think you would have
um I see mubonga you've had asked the
question a bit earlier too do you want
to jump in
uh thank you Rachel so I just want you
to understand from Alan uh what
certifications are in his team because
he did touch on that when he started the
talk
did did you say uh education
I think um so the certified
accreditations I think you mentioned
that accreditations
yes
um yeah so people are interested in I
think there's there's a range there um
so one of the folks on the team has done
a a data science master's degree
um and I think that that's the the most
um that's sort of the the
I don't know kind of top end of formal
training lots of other folks have done
some core some coursework
um some amount of kind of independent
um independent training of of different
kinds of things
um and then you know more generally
folks have we have we have a great we
have a great mix I have a mechanical
engineer on my team
um I have
um
uh you know folks who do physical
engineering and that's really cool and
then this you know range of folks with
with other kinds of backgrounds and
experiences But but so the the you know
the the most anyone on the team has done
formally in terms of data science
training
um would would be something like a like
a um you know a data science masters
right right now
does that help fill in Bongo what you
were were interested in knowing or were
you interested specifically in in any of
those details it does it
it does because that's the kind of mix
that we normally see even in this part
of the world we have different
backgrounds and all fitting into the
team to give a very nice heterogeneous
mix of skills
yeah
like kind of reflecting on that a little
bit
when I came into this role we had a
definition for this data engineer role
that was that really emphasized the
technical the technical kind of
accreditation
um I have really intentionally cast a
broader a broader net than I think we
started with based on the idea that I
think people can be successful coming
from a bunch of places and we really
depend on a deep understanding of our
businesses and our functions for example
and I believe that lots and lots of
people can learn the the technical
pieces but you know there's a business
aptitude there's a there's a
sophistication around how people
interact and solve problems
um that I think has has been a really
really important part of of building my
team and I think I can see that as part
of our our broader success
um you know that that accreditation is
one thing and it demonstrates a
particular kind of of capability that's
important
um but for me at least I really don't
want it to be the only one
Ellen I I know you mentioned this
briefly in the beginning but like one of
your the parts of your role that you
really enjoy is like helping develop
your team and helping them be successful
and I'd love to chat a little bit about
that in here like what you're learning
in this role or what has has been most
helpful
um yeah so I guess as framework I can
say Gore as a company takes that kind of
development really seriously and so we
have some formal processes that try to
structure our approach to it
um so I have some help organizationally
in the fact that there's always a little
bit of a of a reminder that hey we're
coming through our cycle of doing
development planning with our teams and
making sure that we're that we're
thinking about it and talking about it
so the formal element has to do with
trying to do good planning with people
about what are they interested in and
where do they want to go and having con
realistic conversations about okay you
know are the things you're interested in
things that we need right now
um if so great let's let's connect you
to those and make sure that your skills
are developing in a way that feels
rewarding and that is is also getting
getting things done for for our business
and so we have a real deliberate process
of having those conversations and
setting goals that try to you know smart
goal that try to work along along that
path so that a couple times a year we
can say hey are you're checking things
off on your on your plan that could feel
good and let's celebrate we really try
intentionally to
um to do that
um so for me I think
uh that one of the things that I'm I
think learning that I have to figure out
how to do well especially as the team
grows is
how to balance having a like a vision
for where we want to go technically and
also letting my team develop that and
run with it you know a year and a half
ago we were a team of three and all
three of us could be really deep in just
about everything we did and so the one
of the big pivots for me is going okay
now we're working with five or six
different functions we have a lot more
work than I can technically lead anymore
my role is different than it than it was
a year and a half ago and I can still be
really invested in the like Technical
Solutions and the writing code that is
really rewarding for me but the future
direction of the team I've got to let
them
own and so figuring out how to do that
that's one of the things for my
development this year that's really
important for me is figuring out how to
have a vision get buy-in for the vision
and then and then let them run with it
and really be successful with it because
my success is they're doing good work
that is really rewarding and that you
know ultimately we have to get our
business needs done but but success for
us as a team I think will feel really
really great when when they feel like
their skills are developing and they're
doing things that are meaningful to them
in ways that they want to work so I'm
working on all of that balance
and those conversations with them about
like their own skills development and
their own career growth are those like
separate calls that the like company has
like scheduled like annual review type
things are they part of a normal
one-on-one process
um a little bit of both the the process
itself has its own kind of cadence and
Milestones and so we try to you know
work but but I think we try to make that
dedicated time you know I have I have
weekly or bi-weekly catch-ups with folks
on the team and we can check in on those
things at those points in time but we
really also want to have dedicated time
to say like all right let's let's look
at your plan let's talk about your plan
um and then there are also in other
inputs from other places in Gore Gore
has an idea of sponsors and and sponsors
are are a generally person who's not
who's not your leader who who also has a
commitment to that kind of success so
there are multiple places where as an
associate you can get that feedback
um and one of my roles is to try to help
identify those goals and then you know
support people through
um
working towards them
thank you
I see there's a few questions in the
chat and one is I'm not sure if your
name is shared there but it says s
so I could start to read the question or
if you want to jump in and read it
[Music]
would apply for a data engineering world
of your team what kind of skills
experiences Etc would you tend to look
for for coming to convincing
great question
um yeah it's a great question
um I guess I have to give some caveat
that that you know those skills I do
think are important I just don't think
that they're the only sort of thing that
that gets you in that can get you in the
door
um so for example you know working as
um we have people who are who are
successful on our on our broad team who
come from the analyst backgrounds of all
different kinds and from tools
backgrounds of all different kinds and
and they can be successful there and I
think that that applies to to a team
like mine as well I do think that
there's a
um you know there's a
a an element of being competitive for
these kinds of roles it really is rooted
in some some core kind of technical
foundations
um but for example like you know
um
I'm trying to think of a good I'm trying
to think of a good example
um you can be really technical but not a
good problem solver and we really need
people who can be who can be who can
learn the technical things
um but can come in with a perspective on
like what does solving problems well
look like
and I guess I'm thinking of of you know
you can you can be you can be really
technical but uh inflexible I'll say in
in how you solve problems and that's a
really really hard way to be successful
because you can't there's a whole lot of
of what we do in our work that has to do
with it you know we're satisficing we're
getting to a good enough solution that
folks can do work with that we know we
want to improve later
um and a lot of
I think a lot of technical work a lot of
Technical Training is sometimes a little
too black and white for being able to to
compromise about this is good data and
my customers can work with it and I'll
come back and I'll help improve it for
the for the next cycle
you've got to be able to compromise I
think you've got to be able to talk well
through problems and I think you've got
to be able to feel embedded with your
customers so that you're a partner to
them and not a
um not just a technical service I think
that's where you can come into roles
like on teams like like mine but also I
guess I'd encourage you as there are
lots of analytical and Technical roles
that don't necessarily look like data
engineering but that are still doing
analytical work and there's a whole
bunch of space there where I think the
landscape is even more broad for Success
without coming necessarily from you know
what we would look at as the you know
typical like you know
like data engineer software engineer
data scientist background
thanks
um maybe just a follow-up question and
you're talking about
um solving problems or like uh
communicating with Culver history and I
guess
um to show that I would talk about like
previous experiences or maybe show how I
creatively solve a problem in my
projects or something like that thank
you thanks yeah absolutely and those are
the things you know being able to to get
that I'm thinking of like interviews
that I've been part of that have been
really fun you see people light up when
they when they say I solved this problem
and it involved a bunch of different
kinds of cooperation and I got to be
creative
um you know seeing that is is really
really fun and that's the kind of thing
that I think helps you
you know in processes that I think have
have worked well it helps people really
stand out is to be able to to describe
the kinds of things that you were
describing
Javier had a comment that I'm trying to
catch up and read what everybody's
commenting on but there seems like
there's a lot of plus ones to it so
Javier do you want to jump in
thanks Rachel
um Alan I just I really love your
position on how to have about or how to
grow like a balanced diverse data
science org or engineering org and I
don't feel like most hiring managers out
there kind of scare your same thoughts
um and yeah I just I I proposed it would
be awesome if you wrote like a medium
post or you know if you have a personal
blog if you wrote some kind of post on
this because I think the more and more
voices are out there like publicly
saying you know we don't need to hire
phds for a growing team exclusively
um
you know it would just be a win-win for
everybody
but thank you I've loved your feedback
thanks um no I I really really
appreciate that that's that's great um
that's super affirming for me so I so
I'm I'm grateful for that input
um I do yeah I I think
um
I do look around you know I've had
conversations with folks doing like data
science certificates of different kinds
and I do this probably ranges a little
bit kind of kind of around around with
your comment a little bit Javier but I
think we I don't always know if we if we
do a service to people the way we set
them up for what we
as an industry data science tends tends
to look like
um I know my team is unique
um in the way that we're positioned
within our organization right there's a
whole bunch of our founding conditions
that describe how we how we get to where
we are right
um but and so I know there are lots of
teams that do look like that sort of
sort of archetypical data science org
um but I don't know if it's I don't know
if it's the right expectation for people
going through data science training to
have their eyes on you know the the like
machine learning engineer kind of kind
of career for example
um you know there aren't there aren't a
ton of them the applications are pretty
specific
um we're a pretty sophisticated business
and we're trying to figure out what some
of those things mean to us and how to
effectively use them and don't get me
wrong I'm really excited for my team to
be where we develop that expertise
um but without the without the business
need it's not fair for me to tell people
like come join my team and be a data
scientist the way that the way that sort
of the world says data science looks
um it's it's going to be technical it's
going to be interesting it's going to be
rewarding but it's different from from
that other picture and that's I think we
have to be realistic and
um I don't think there's any reason we
can't make people really excited about
that kind of work it's really cool work
it's really complex the problems to
solve are really fun the platforms we
get to work with are really cool
um it just but it looks a little
different so I think we have to be
realistic and and I think we
um I think this expansive view of and
and I'm kind of going on and on but so
as a job code the folks on my team are
data scientists that's the way that's
what people we call them in PeopleSoft
and I think that's the the but the work
right now that we talk about and that I
hire people for is data engineering and
so we've what I like that we've set up
is we've got a lot of runway for folks
with a broad set of skills to come into
my team
I have to be really realistic about what
I promise the work is going to look like
and when so that we're not bringing in
people who have a very particular vision
of data science that that we just can't
offer there are other places that can
um I would love for folks on my team to
be able to do that kind of work when
we're ready for it and when we've got
the skill but we're on a path
thank you
yeah thanks for that thanks for comment
I really really appreciate it
I see there was an anonymous question a
bit earlier that was I work at an
investment bank and everything in
reporting is mainly run in Excel what
helped you in connecting our and or
python to your company's database
um we've actually talked about our
infrastructure a little bit
um I said that that we're we're
pragmatic data engineering and so some
of that means
um some of that means for some projects
it makes sense to connect to some
databases and do some Transformations
with python and produce something on the
other end
um the the biggest the biggest kind of
piece of infrastructure that we have in
place right now is a set of Integrations
um not written in Python
um that that for that that build
um in conjunction with a bunch of other
mechanics build a big data Mark that
feed a significant population of our
analysts who use Tableau against it
so
um uh so I guess to to get back to the
question how have we had success doing
something like that I guess we've had
success where it made sense for the use
case to do data polls using python
um I bring in our whenever I get to sit
down and do something because I I like
to work with it
um and but again it's it's you know the
sort of the right tool for the job
and one of the jobs that we've had over
the last several years is is bringing
together a bunch of data from some
complex data sources
having a pretty deep business
understanding and helping to feed this
this big data Mart
um
that's pretty you know like that's not
the it's not the thing necessarily that
you put like on the data science
recruiting poster but it's but it's
really really critical and the folks who
have done that work are hugely talented
and absolutely critical for our team's
success and have
um
uh
I think developed as part of that
program a ton of really great skills so
I guess
um
[Music]
I don't know if this is a good answer to
to the original question I would say if
if if python connecting to finance data
as an alternative to spreadsheets
helps get the work done that you need to
get done that's the case that you make
to anybody who is who you need to get
buy-in or permission from or or whatever
um and if in that method you can then
render out the kind of data products
that your customers need then it's
success and and then you've gotta then
you've got a cycle where you can say hey
I worked through this python oriented
method to provide data to customers it
worked let's expand the scope let's
upscale the the number of people who
rely on this and and so on
um
uh so I I hope that's kind of speaking
to to that to that question
um I I don't know if it is
um
I don't remember who who asked it I
think it is
anonymous but but I think it is I um I
love Libby's comment too which goes
along with us like data science is not
one thing and I'm thinking math might be
the title of uh this conversation on
you do
um Daniel I see you had asked a question
in the chat do you want to jump in
yeah yeah sure thank you
um so it was really just going back to a
comment that you had made about kind of
balancing I think when when you'd first
mentioned it balancing kind of like
division uh aspects of a leader and the
the kind of like the technical expertise
that people in these roles generally
have
uh and so really I was just hoping that
you could elaborate that a little bit
more and kind of like how you handle
that balance
uh the the general background being
where I am generally speaking the the
higher up you go the less technical you
are in terms of just kind of like title
uh and I'm kind of at the the first
inflection point now where I'm beginning
that transition from kind of like person
who's turned to for a lot of technical
things to being more kind of like the
people leader uh and that balance is
something I struggle with yeah no I hear
you I I think I'm feeling a lot of that
of that same thing for me I think the a
big part of the reason the work is
rewarding is being Technical and so
selfishly I don't want to work myself
out of a out of a job that it that is at
least somehow somehow Hands-On
um and I think I'm working on figuring
out how to
um like influence with some with some
kind of vision but also being really
open to what are the tools that the
folks on my on my team want to use
what's going to be rewarding for them
and sort of sort of letting them run
so maybe there's kind of a kind of a
path there where
um
you know if I'm maybe part of the
technical piece is for me is figuring
out like what's the potential solution
in space and I need to be able to
understand that enough that I can be
like an advocate for the for the kinds
of tools that people want to use and
understand them well enough to
you know do do administrative things
like like make investment forecasts like
how much is this going to cost and can
we can we afford it should we afford it
right those are still those still
require me being technical enough to
understand the the payoff and the the um
the constraints and the costs and
benefits and things like that
um the I mean I'm really really lucky
right now in that I can be strategic and
I can go into conversations about our
like Enterprise Global analytics
Direction and I hope the influential on
behalf of my team and then in the
afternoon I can look at code with
someone on my team and we can sort of
ideate together like what is a good a
good solution look like that kind of be
able to do both of those is just great
and so you know I would hope that I
don't end up in a role where I don't get
to have to have that mix
um so I guess you know ultimately I
think I'm really sympathetic to the kind
of position you're in right now Daniel
of of like what is good people
leadership look like and is that
rewarding while at the same time being
able to to be Technical and Hands-On
um and I think I'm lucky in my
organization that I'm able to do some
balancing of it
um and I hope I can continue to to
figure it out and hope to do it well
but yeah it's hard
yeah understood
thanks very much very much
thank you I see uh Marlene you had asked
a question as well you want to jump in
sure hi Alan we're twinning by the way
yay
um so
um
truth bomb I kind of hate project
management I I kind of do like I really
enjoy rolling up my sleeves and getting
dirty with the data right
um so
it doesn't mean that I'm not good at it
or I can't do it but I I struggle with
hey is this something I really should
kind of get some formal training with
and or I mean I imagine anybody in the
data space at some point might consider
having people work under them you
obviously have a team under you I'm just
playing with the idea of do I actually
go out and get formal training for
project management I think imprint you
know managing employees is probably
something that's worth looking at to
understand like
good Dynamics and hierarchy and managing
personalities but my my question to you
was how what part of your role since
you're there did you prepare for or
maybe you had some empathy before
aptitude for excuse me going into it and
then what did you feel like you kind of
needed and or maybe even your company
just said Alan you're assuming this role
here's what this training that you got
to do now in order to assume this role
that's kind of my my thought process
um that that last bit implies a lot of
organization
um up front about knowing what to to
tell people they now need to do
um a lot of a lot of leadership at Gore
is kind of evolving into a commitment
that that may be expanding and and then
learning what are all the things that
you don't uh what are the organizational
things that you just you had no no idea
about
um you know I I've had to to learn like
how how do I make an a budget forecast
um personally I have I have good
um my team leader the person who
provides leadership to me is really
really supportive of like helping me
figure those things out
um but that's not Universal and a lot of
those things I think you sort of sort of
stumble along
um my my prior it roles were a little
bit closer to not formally but in
function I had to do a lot of sort of
portfolio planning
um and also at various points I was
everything from a like a project manager
to just a a team member or a champion of
a of a project
but I never had any formal like project
management training either
um and so I learned a lot from other
parts of our organization that do that
work and that evolved sort of in
parallel with with my moving through
various roles so you know we could look
to a project management organization to
understand understand some elements of
planning and to occasionally even like
tap into their resources
um I think one thing that as we've grown
from a sales marketing oriented function
to a divisionally oriented function a a
capability Gap that I'm learning how to
fill now is how do I understand what
everybody needs from us how to make good
predictions about when we can do the
work how long it will take how many
resources we'll need Etc and have that
be more than just a really wild guess
um you know that that's one of the
things that I think will be really
really key for us
but again I you know I'm not trying
there are certifications in that stuff
for sure
um I think a team like ours could use
probably a dedicated person but we're
not able to we're not able to dedicate
those you know those resources
um one of the things from from a call
two or three weeks ago the Toronto
Health System folks I think they
described it they win their team formed
they had a portfolio manager or someone
to that effect that to me is such
would be such an important kind of
founding condition for Success going
forward to say from the jump we want to
have people who are helping us to
organize this portfolio of work
um I think my experience across a bunch
of roles it is really hard to come to
late
um but that doesn't mean we shouldn't be
thoughtful uh thoughtful about it
that is super helpful I really
appreciate all those comments and I
think you're right on the coming late to
the show because people get real set in
their ways and management does not like
to kind of have somebody come in and
it's like hurting cats right they don't
want their stuff messed with or their
toys played with
um yeah so yeah I appreciate that so so
much thank you that definitely answers
my question thanks
thank you Tiffany there's a lot of great
questions coming into and I I think
Tiffany you asked one a little bit
earlier do you want to jump in
yeah
um I hi I had a recent discussion with a
hiring manager I'm looking for a job put
that out there
um and it was for like the senior data
analyst position and they were kind of
concerned that like me being more of a
data scientist that I would be kind of
bored with doing the data analyst role
and you talked about how your team I
guess their titles would be data
scientists but they're more data
engineers and I guess what do you think
the differences are between those
foreign
there's a whole uh there's a whole lot
there that I think is pretty loaded
um I guess
I had I had I had a similar conversation
um in in hiring at one point about
um basically the end of which was was
was saying hey I I don't think it's the
question about about like the are you
over are you overqualified are you gonna
get bored
um like I think that's for you that's
that's your
um like that's for you to think about I
think I I think if we take seriously
people who are interested in our in our
roles we ought to think about like are
they are they qualified for for for this
work
um and trust trust that they are when
they apply for our jobs that they're
interested in them I guess
um so I guess but that's a little kind
of orthogonal to to the question about
the differentiation between the roles
but I guess I think it's important for
I think it's important for us to
acknowledge that when we're when we're
looking for people that we could like
think seriously what they say they want
to do
um in terms of the difference I mean I
I think there's a lot of fluidity
between them and and that's why I think
it's important to say aspirationally
my we call the folks on my team data
scientists most of the work is probably
what we call data engineering
I don't think I'd I'd draw a bright line
distinction between them though I think
that if the
if the distinction between data
engineering and data science is a
um is a technical one about like the
methodologies that you use are you know
are you doing machine learning or are
you doing you know complex data
management processes I think that makes
it really mechanical in a way that I
don't know if it if it serves Us in
either situation your your profiling
information you're asking questions of
data you have to be responsive to the
things that you're that your
stakeholders need
um and
I think I think doing data engineering I
don't know maybe this is provocative but
I think doing data engineering is a kind
of data science and I think that doing
data engineering is also foundational I
think that performing data science also
involves doing a lot of data engineering
so I don't think I would like draw a
super bright line but I do think that
that people who are hiring and people
who are leading teams and people who are
doing the work need to have really
serious honest conversations about like
what kind of work does this role need
and does that look like the stuff that I
want to do the stuff that I've trained
for the stuff that I've you know
envisioned myself doing and if not then
yeah I think you need to be really
honest about okay maybe it's not the
right the right fit but but I think that
they are I think that they're so tightly
linked that it's really hard to
um
um
to differentiate in a clean way I don't
know if that if that helps Tiffany
no I think that this was kind of the
discussion that we had it's just it's
kind of hard to distinguish between what
these different rules are and Define uh
what you would be doing and yeah so
thank you and and you're welcome and I
guess just to be really clear I guess I
don't want to I don't want to suggest
that they're like interchangeable or
um that there isn't some uniqueness of
of the skill sets I I think it because
there's potentially so much overlap I
think people have to be really clear
about what's involved in this job and
what do I want to do and be really
honest and and serious about about those
kinds of things because because for sure
you know you do different there are lots
and lots of different kinds of work to
do in this whole
agglomerated thing of data science and
data engineering businesses need to be
really honest about what they need and
they need to understand it seriously and
you know the rest of us need to think
about
um but does that fit with what we want
to do and can we and can we get the job
there
I love all this conversation about being
really honest about
what they're going to do in that role
but also for somebody looking for the
role like making sure it's clear what
you really want to be doing too
um on the like topic of of job postings
and hiring too Jackie I see yes the
question earlier too do you want to jump
in
oh which question was that
um I think it was about so it was about
computer science as a preferred degree
yeah I was just wondering what your
views are on
was it um I can read it too I think I
don't remember have it handy I see job
posting State computer science as a
preferred degree what's the view on
self-taught versus formal education
um I mean I'm a sociologist and I
convinced people that I could do this
stuff so I'm I'm biased towards saying I
don't think computer science should be a
a preferred degree
um a couple people on my team have CS
backgrounds and degrees and they're
great
um I don't think it's the only way to be
successful I mean I think if you look
around the community there are you know
so many that this community that our
studio and posit has been such a I think
foundational positive part of there are
all these people who come into this kind
of work without that background and
they're great
um and so for me I want to be really
encouraging of
not needing to come through that
um that particular pipeline
um it doesn't it doesn't exclude you of
course
um but I think there are tons and tons
of ways to come at it without
um you know there are all kinds of
people who are who are super technical
and do really fascinating complex
interesting technical stuff who aren't
um who don't come out of computer
science they come from you know history
and literature and
um social science
um so you know that's yeah that's
obviously my baggage right
but but yeah I don't think you need to I
don't think you should need a CS degree
thanks Alan
I see there's quite a conversation
happening in the chat right now which I
love when there's a conversation going
on in the chat too I can't catch up I'm
quick enough but I
I
think
um there was another question you had
asked earlier Libby about
um Community or knowledge sharing do you
want to jump in yeah I don't think I
could even scroll back to find that but
I was asking
asking if Gore had any type of internal
data science Community or knowledge
sharing stuff set up and I think that
the other part of my question was kind
of like
the value that you put on good
communication inside of an engineering
role like are your roles business
partner roles where like that's really
important for relationship building
two-parter sorry yeah
um on the on the community one I think
we're we're working on it you know we
have
um my team is a little bit unique in
structure within our Enterprise right
now but there are uh individuals and
um and other teams sort of forming and I
you know and and we have
some of them are in are in whole other
businesses and so we don't necessarily
have a natural connectivity to them but
we're aware of you know
um you know we're aware of them out
there we're trying to build some sort of
networking so that we can you know share
good practices or at least like at least
see each other as peers out there doing
similar work even if it's not the same
work or or even if our our tools and
stuff are really are really different
um so so I guess I'd say like yes
um sometimes Gore feels like a really
big company and it feels like it's hard
to connect to those sorts of folks and
other times it's really natural
um and we can you know reach out and
collaborate and and communicate
um so yeah um maybe young I guess in
that sense Libby like the the real
formal sense of of community
um within our MPD analytics team I think
we have a great sense of community it's
a really
it's a really good team to to be a part
of
um even though you know my team is a
piece of the of the whole
um and in terms of
um
um the second part of your question
about sort of the the partnership I
think that we're successful because we
are such close Partners to our to our
our customers
um we don't
right now we're I'm sort of figuring out
with the folks on my team should we have
you know should a person on my team be
dedicated to doing work with our quality
Organization for example or does my team
kind of kind of float and sort of you
know fill needs as they come up on
projects and I think there are pros and
cons of both of those but thinking about
your question of what does the
partnership look like I think you know
we do well when we have good close
relationships with our our customers and
that means that as data folks we
understand the business we understand
the functional needs
um so that we don't have to
um
you know so that they so right so that
like they trust us they know that we
understand their problems enough to help
to help to solve them so yeah I think
the partnership is close whether it's
dedicated or not I think we're we're
gonna figure out
um but I think it's important for us to
feel like we're part of the organization
that's like substantively doing the work
so maybe that's where the value of the
partnership is really really important
you know we're we're the data team but
we're part of an analytics team that is
deeply deeply embedded in the business
and the functions that we work with and
I think that's good for us
and good for them too I think it's good
for everybody I agree yeah I think
that's fantastic like having people that
can really build relationships with the
people who are the end users of whatever
you're doing
is so important thank you for sharing
yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely I see um Marlene you had
mentioned you had a great visual that
helps you understand how data science is
not one thing so the love to see that at
some point but I also see um Megan you
had a great comment as well about that
previous conversation I was wondering if
you wanted to share that here too
yeah sure
um yeah I just
found that
um I hadn't asked questions when I was
interviewing as a candidate around what
the difference is in the job role around
um like what the core work would be
versus maybe projects that sounded
really flashy but were not
um a bulk of the work so just
yeah just a suggestion to keep in mind
as you're interviewing to understand as
a data analyst or scientist what kind of
those differences are might be a good
question just to make sure it's
something that you want to be doing like
on a daily basis or something like that
definitely yeah yeah I think asking as
an as a candidate what's the day-to-day
you know what do most days look like
um is really important and then also as
a as an interviewer having people on the
on the interview team who can speak
directly to that is really important
um you know so so when when we're hiring
you know we always have
um sort of analyst kind of customer
facing folks on the team to be able to
explain like what do our customers need
and also at least someone from my team
who can answer that question what's the
day-to-day like
um because that's really important
Mike I see you asked two great questions
so maybe whichever one you like best
first
so I I was poking back into what you
were talking about in project management
um I think it's fair to say that there's
probably a lot of people on the call who
effectively are doing their own project
management within their own team
um so outside of the kind of
um budgeting aspect which is I think
probably a different conversation but do
you have any quick wins or quick tips on
the the kind of management side of
project management rather than that can
a more formal discipline
um that's a good question
um
quick wins in project management
um I guess or or stakeholder management
might be another
we so we we talk a lot maybe maybe two
things that I can try and say really
quickly we talk a lot within my team in
the bigger analytical team about feeling
comfortable pushing back on requests and
saying what are you going to do with
this deliverable what are you going to
do different or what's going to be
value-added because of it that is a
really helpful clarifying question not
only in terms of managing scope but also
in terms of better understanding what
success looks like because often the
thing that they say they're going to do
isn't necessarily
a direct line from what they asked from
what they asked for
um so being confident enough and having
enough credibility as a big team to say
to ask that I think is really really
good for us and then you can get into
the to the more detailed kind of project
management
um stuff
um and I think I said I had two two
thoughts there and I I've I have no
recollection now what the what the
second one is
um but that one for us I think is is a
really important reaching a milestone
where we could push back in on in terms
of scope was I think a really
significant one for us and the way that
I think we crystallize that is to say
okay what are you gonna do
um you know help us Define that and and
I think that's really really a a key one
yeah I can imagine that because you go
from what are you what what are you what
do you think you're asking for yeah and
what were you actually needing yeah
exactly yeah tell us how you're gonna
act if we make this thing or if we give
you a versus B what do you do
differently
um is it's really key for everybody I
think
thank you so much for all these awesome
questions I want to make sure that there
isn't something that I've missed or like
really pressing question you want to
make sure you ask
here so feel free to just like unmute
yourself and jump in too
I think we got everything
awesome thank you so much Alan this is
great thank you this this is fun and
um yeah slightly self-indulgently I
think you know just real quick having
this community sort of being able to be
a part of over the last year or so has
been really great super validating
um and uh you know congrats posit on
being posit
um you know that's a such a big
milestone and and really fun and uh yeah
you all are a big part I think of why so
many of us feel like this is a community
we can be a part of so I'm really really
grateful and this was really fun fun to
chat with everybody super happy to to
talk more if folks want to find me
um and um uh really happy to look around
and like feel like a peer to a bunch of
folks so thank you
absolutely thank you so much Alan I was
just saying that today when I was
sharing on LinkedIn like it's so fun
seeing like getting to meet somebody for
the very first time that comes into the
space and then seeing people like come
back and get to know each other too and
feeling like we all really know each
other and have met in person even though
I haven't met everybody in person yet
right
um but yeah this has been great thank
you so much really appreciate it have a
great day thank you all take care Rachel
I posted the visual I've talked about on
my list and then um there's a second
visual that I'll put up really soon too
that helps I think it's from data Camp
it really shows like the difference
between what at least somebody has a
guideline right architect versus
engineer versus scientist versus
analysts database admin and so I'm using
it to help my company to kind of
understand that there is no one thing to
rule them all right you need multiple
people to help handle what's on this
workload at least understand it but Alan
this has been great thank you so much
for sharing all your candid insights and
and experience it's been oh yeah my
pleasure Marlene thank you
thank you yeah and I'll take that post
over and and make sure it goes into the
group too so if we want to continue a
conversation on that too I feel like
there's a lot of thoughts to be shared
there
sure thanks Rachel cool thank you
everybody